interesting that he doesn't go B5 here I
think he played B5 previously and a
bunch of times I remember
and then there's some Knight A3 lines
which uh get a bit weird
yeah so B6 Bishop should be seven and
then uh fiance doing the other one as
well
and Arjun replies very very directly by
occupying the center with everything he
can and Magnus doesn't really challenge
it yet because uh Knight C3 supports the
pawn on D5 very well against both E6 and
C6 and goes Knight A6 for the time being
uh I assume you want Knight C5 maybe you
want Knight fe4 then maybe you want to
even support a bit of 705 if that
happens uh A5 is useful with the Knight
on C5 just to support it against the
uh
move before Knight D4 I remember being
one one of the most testing lines yeah
that looks very logical
um or black has to play five pretty much
before you get cramped and we get some
weird Kings Indian where
yeah Knight C2 or Knight B3 something
somewhere somewhere any other choice
here here has to be between 93 and
Knight C2 yeah I don't think we very
much want to play this I think this
gives black yeah like black just
breathes up very heavy sigh of relief if
this happens nice absolutely absolutely
no point for why to give up on
very nice
space grabbing 495 yeah what do we think
of this king's Indian seems very
playable for black eye I'm not a huge uh
a huge uh specialist in in these types
of structures but it feels like in
particular with Bishop on C1 and not F2
you can definitely play three and before
you can you probably should be doing it
right this moment yeah but let's say I
don't know a3h5 before we just do 9b7 I
think we don't even take on before for
for now because we don't want to open
the a file uh for white to try and uh
exploit
how are we going to learn C4 C5
it was like a distant dream at this
moment
workers very understandable play right
yeah G5 G4 maybe even fgh GH4 in some
positions very worried about this to be
honest I don't think this is such a big
problem
but yeah a three plate so now we will we
will I think see uh very clearly what
Magnus feels about a3a4 because if you
want to do it you want you you probably
do it right this moment absolutely
ignores the idea of B3 before
says be my guest I'm a bit surprised
he's done it this way though because now
yeah he's allowed this this honestly
feels wrong to me I will yeah I mean
it's a kind of a strong statement but it
really does feel very wrong to me
because I will play G4 I will play H3
let's H5 H3 and I think we might even
have time enough in this positions in
general to just like get it over to C2
like just straight away yeah I don't
know Knight F6 we go King F2 we go Rook
H1 and we just park it on C2 eventually
I don't think black will be able to open
very much anywhere honestly a bit of a
mystery to me why we're starting with
this and not this
chicken here and go G4 you can for now
at least you can definitely continue
ignoring it but
it also feels quite logical from his
Viewpoint I think because H5 G4 is
happening quite quickly like if you if
you make a move here whichever whichever
movie you want to so I think he goes
Knight B7 without the trade the trade is
never running away why this is not the
bayonet here 97 already played ba5 is
never a good idea here compared to some
of the bayonet positions the G4 played
and the match yeah and there's there's
some people in chat who are very adamant
that this is not much better for white
uh I don't know if I necessarily agree
but I do feel it's a it's a massive
Improvement compared to uh what we could
have had if Magnus didn't allow the king
side to be closed I really am mystified
by by the choice of G5 over H5 here
you'd really like day four
but it also sort of like page five it
just didn't like G5 very much making
some
strong positional moves such as wish
page six and claiming that this is going
to be annoying
um yeah also not very obvious to me
because like Bishop G2 followed by A5
will happen very quickly as we know from
but it's all in the past and uh yeah
yeah you you do have to wonder G5 was
played very very quickly by Magnus
uh which felt like he didn't really want
to consider
any other options
neither side really wanted to touch the
king side too much that can build up
there somehow but yeah okay seven played
and now
uh looks like this is going to be very
very difficult to shift it's like a
textbook position if uh he's Indian uh
yeah plans what's what does either side
do but here it feels like not too much
take a look at what's uh happening uh in
the challengers as we've mentioned just
a moment ago in magnus's game uh
somewhere here Roger look H7 which one
out of six King E1 Rook B2 Queen D3
uh apparently
eight days before was massively
massively strong here and he kind of
missed the opportunity I'm guessing with
the intention of playing okay one and
then if King D1 is it that we just go go
in or you know if there is if it's
something strong it must be connected to
giving up material and going in yeah
actually it doesn't even go okay one and
goes HGH dc6 C6 so connection of all the
plants all the openings uh the black
Brooks are on nice files and if I I
don't really want to suggest taking on
D6 but just to show that takes D6 in B8
maybe
or queen C7 B8 I guess I don't know
yeah I guess White's just stuck
um loads of pieces on the back rank
weakness on B4 yeah I think he wants to
take on G4 because I think white like my
initial reaction was we just go to and
then both pairs come off but maybe we
take on B1 I can take an H2 then yeah
well I can take one H2 and yeah you
you're definitely not doing this right I
don't think so unless you want to go
unless you want to do a complete Goblin
mode and like to do this but that never
works that is not a few pieces yeah
I guess his plan is then maybe go for
this right and then and now and now
we're there and now we do come in you
could see this going very wrong for
whites if you allow the bishop to move
in G4
but uh too tempy how did that Bishop get
to that one
three page three which page five
kind of locking your own Bishop behind
the chain which is unusual and likely to
heal of course whitewood's very very
happy to snap on G3 in all of these
positions yeah I'm just freeing
everything up with one even snapping on
F4 might have been a semi threat yeah
with one so what do we do
looking position move 40 for Magnus 27
minutes yeah he did all he could to
force uh Arjun to play uh under some
time pressure but Arjun got to move
forward even five minutes reasonably
calm we obviously have to establish by
five the question is
is there anything smarter than Knight H6
I mean you can allow it like you can
play something like G3 here but that
allows Queen G1
or F3 F3 I don't like it F3 now or yeah
I don't like it I think I think that
introduces all kinds of ideas to to why
that you don't want to introduce five
instead of Knight H6 after
reasonably prolonged thought that's
question no he played it fast yeah
before is hanging so my default reaction
here is Knight bc3 it's not now Bishop
F5 is back to being a threat I assume
Maybe
should take C4 sometimes is the answer
there yeah one of the nice has to land
on C3
um
for Arjun you feel like this one is
still kind of a guessing game it's yeah
very much is who's better and why
maybe Quincy twos an idea as well as
Knight C3 I was just trying to look for
Prince just to threaten Knight takes F4
as well as Bishop F5 that sounds like uh
and now black pretty solid second option
very unusual position in the game
between uh Arjun and Magnus where uh
Arjun took a while here to make a
decision almost half an hour uh
20-ish minutes
spent on Knight C3
now Magnus very quickly played Bishop 3.
further supporting the setup on the king
side I don't know how to create any of
this me neither If This Were a game I
would just kind of forget trying to
think who's better who's worse it's just
pure calculation and yeah
um really does feel like a like you're I
think severely incentivized not to not
to even try to understand what's
happening
press the clock wait for our opponent to
decide on something
it's just play Queen F1 in terms of ease
of play
um who would you favor I think I would
take the pawns just because it's at
least clear what you're doing as black
uh Mars would be the plan but uh yeah
the engine was sort of severely in
severe disagreement with this
for some reason specifically because of
Queen H4
okay which I don't think is very obvious
uh what's the idea Q5 GT now G3 G2
simply I don't know maybe it improves
Bishop F6 or something yeah already
played by by the players in magnus's
game I mean aesthetically you just want
to play Knight F7 right you just want to
re-establish full control over the E5
Pawn a square and then just start
pushing there might be something faster
but knowing that the computer wanted to
play Queen H4 last move and maybe again
Queen H4 but yeah Knight F7 looks so
human F7 looks very very nice and we're
allowing C5 but C5 really feels like it
might just be opening
you know like files files for the black
queen yeah
to start attacking the king I'm really
attracted to Queen A8 even though it
doesn't it doesn't really uh guarantee
any checkmates so am I uh don't know
what else black could try here you can
go and buy a while this at this angle
Direction because I think 97 is oh hang
on this is kind of over the magic boom
yeah
I didn't spot it immediately but it is a
bit problematic I was wondering where
you're going on the second round I was
like there's no entry points but this is
a nice way yeah because I thought I was
actually originally planning to injury
tour but then like 90 Acres 98 check is
a bit of a bit of an issue yeah I mean
it's still good but can we play five
five and and then 97 but as I now
realize yeah this is what he does I
think what they maybe this is very
important right yeah that we're
controlling E8
and threatening and meeting a couple of
moves uh yeah
doing a few moves if white reacts
apparently Bishop takes and D is even
stronger
Bishop take T5 here yeah
and after 97 I suppose
what Professor is arguing for here is
that F6 is just a very very safe square
like I can play Queen A4 here and this
is just one check because an iPhone 7
covers absolutely everything more than
borderline yeah plus yeah plus I mean
you have Bishop C3 but then you will
just lose those end games like Queen B3
should be doing I can go G3 for now
and just continue continue cleaning my
stuff on the king size 98. yeah 98 now
exists yes so we maybe take everything
off the board first and then go into
three right yeah it looks clean very
fast pawns the move we said might be
difficult just visually but very strong
yeah I think once again you just need to
fight past the uh the fear of allowing a
lot of counter Play Because generally in
these King's Indians allowing the Knight
to lend only six
uh is something that you are very
apprehensive about but here it just does
not generate
enough play at all F5 is hanging it
doesn't really have good squares Bishop
D3 4 continues becoming you know more
and more of a problem and if you go back
to C2
I assume we wouldn't let the xc4 is very
very strong uh Arjun goes by six check
knocking of seven is actually the only
move winning but it is I think very
findable you don't want to go yeah king
of seven played yeah
was really not expecting him to miss
that
yeah
so Bishop B6 it doesn't matter where we
get okay yeah she's irrelevant now with
1966 on the board yeah
um Bishop B6 check are we going to G6
yeah I think I think we're always going
to just it's just a very very safe
square there's nothing to to even try
I'm really surprised that arjun's
actually taking the knights off the
board because now it does feel like uh
it's very one-sided it should buy if
he's playing for a Perpetual but does it
exist and black triceps yeah what are
the odds of Magnus finding Queen h8 here
I think they're very high at this point
very high yeah I think I would struggle
with my full board awareness to kind of
look back in that direction for a while
but see if you see that nothing else
works then maybe
and okay Levon has resigned that's
confirmed now so Parham takes the win
and Magnus plays Queen h8 yep all right
great move and I have a feeling this is
easy to miss as well like if you're
forced to find it as black you'll find
it but for Arjun it might come as a bit
of a cold shower nope he immediately
replies I was wrong it should be three
yeah and now which long queen move is a
queen H1
you know I'm wondering what the cleanest
way is to win do we just push pawns and
hope for the best
before Bishop takes B6 on the board in
the meantime and for some reason
the easiest Victory here is the move
Queen H2 uh but G3 is also is also
winning
that is a very nice uh brutal move yeah
wow and uh meanwhile back to the game
feeder it looks like um
Bishop G1 I guess the intention is 25 if
we give a check and then we go King A2
and we claim this isn't made
which maybe it isn't
but it feels like it should be
the bishop I want to play bishop move
here Bishop D1 or Bishop I'm not sure D1
but you can also just go Queenie two and
continue improving while not really
allowing any kind to play uh that looks
yeah that looks like and then maybe
Queen G3 Bishop D1 actually will give
mate
yeah
what is hopefully it looks like here uh
totally stalinated pretty much yeah you
you can't really move any of your pieces
and like you play B5 because what else
do you play
and then this comes in and you realize
you you cannot actually stop doing the
three made in any way that makes any
sense
yeah and to continue to continue
covering the the final standings uh 11
the record are on fifty percent
uh level losing yeah both of them
actually losing in the last round to to
go uh below the plus score looked like a
very very promising start that game with
black against Blue Cash looked
fabulous really did look uh very very
good
um
to get some games under his dealt yeah
uh obviously not the kind of training he
would have liked he would have very much
enjoyed I think doing well and the
additional confidence before world
championship match will you know he's
never going to go I miss 11th 12th of
gukesh who was on -4 after I think seven
rounds and recovered quite well and
there we have the the handshake of the
queen D3 I guess the point being if you
play Queen C2 here Queen A3 Queen A2
Queen before check and then eventually
give a check from G1 the eventual
outcome so yeah a nice final picture
with black for Magnus